-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back
to the captain's quarters
on the S.S. Pandemic.
As we've established, I found
my way here via a portal
that connects my attic door
to my in-laws' fireplace,
leading many of you to ask,
"What's happening in the attic
now that you're gone?"
Well, according to my dear
friend and attic sitter,
Ethan Hawke, the wasps
have taken over
the cameras and are filming
their very own late night show.
But apparently they spend
the whole time complaining
about this one moth who's
king of the insects.
And, I don't know,
to me it sounds like
that would get pretty
repetitive.
And speaking of dumb jokes,
the president shook up
his flailing campaign
as the coronavirus outbreak
spirals further out of control.
And now, he's honing in on two
key reelection strategies --
less testing and more racism.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Given that the country is
currently on fire
after a once-in-a-century
cataclysm inflamed
by the president's cruelty
and incompetence,
he's had some trouble
coming up with a solid
re-election message.
It's not a great sign when your
own campaign manager
is advertising face masks
with your name on them.
Each breath you take could be
the one that kills you!
Four more years?
Which is why he called a fake
press conference on Tuesday
to spin his wheels
and try out yet another
deranged campaign message --
the Democrats want to
abolish everything.
-These are actual key elements
of the Biden-Sanders
unity platform.
Abolish immigration detention.
They're going to abolish
immigration enforcement.
Abolish law enforcement
as we know it.
Abolish completely
the death penalty.
They want to abolish
our police departments.
our prisons, I guess.
Abolish all charter schools.
Abolish
educational standards.
Abolish in the suburbs --
You're going to abolish
the suburbs with this.
-First of all, most of that
sounds awesome.
All you're doing is listing
a bunch of things people hate
and claiming the Democrats
will get rid of them.
"Democrats want to abolish
telemarketers, the DMV,
gate-crashing at the airport,
and in-laws."
And of course, I would never
abolish in-laws.
If someone else owned this
house, they'd probably want me
to cease taping a television
show immediately.
Also, I love
how transparent he is
that he's just making stuff up
when he says,
"They want to abolish prisons,
I guess."
He sounds like your dad
describing a movie he saw on TNT
last night as he was
falling asleep.
"They were on a boat, I guess,
and Tom Hanks was in it,
I think.
It was just a disagreement
as to who was captain."
-I'm the captain.
-Oh, sorry, I wasn't
talking about you.
-Okay.
-Third, when Trump said
Democrats want to abolish
the suburbs, he was talking
about a program
implemented by the Obama
administration to desegregate
the suburbs by enforcing
the Fair Housing Act of 1968,
which outlawed
discrimination
and racial segregation
in housing.
So not only was Trump's lie
racist, it was absurd.
He makes it sound like Democrats
are trying to ban
strip malls and cul-de-sacs.
"They want to take away
your Hot Topics
and your Auntie Anne's.
But we're not gonna let that
happen, folks."
Without suburbs, who will
borrow our pruning shears
and not return them?
Where will our adorable
space aliens land
and befriend our children?
Where will our fathers
painstakingly restore
classic cars in a vein
and desperate attempt
to recapture their youth?
This is all Trump has left,
racist grievance politics.
In the middle
of a raging pandemic
that is spiraling out
of control,
has killed nearly
140,000 Americans,
and put tens of millions
out of work, the president
took time out of his day to pose
with a bunch of Goya
food products
on the Oval Office desk.
Well, at least he didn't have to
clear anything off his desk
to take this photo.
He looks like a divorcée
trying to prove he's fine
by posting on Facebook,
"About to make dinner.
So sorry, Leslie, I guess I can
do this by myself."
But at least that smile --
that smile
on the president's face
is sincere.
Let's punch in on that.
Jesus.
He looks like he just took
a big swig of ice water
and forgot he had
a temporary filling.
The U.S. set a record for new
daily coronavirus cases
on Tuesday,
but by all means,
celebrate with
a chocolate wafer.
And to anyone who would promote
a product from the Oval Office
during a pandemic,
Goya [bleep] yourself.
-Good one, Seth.
-Thank you, Captain.
-Thank you for the wordplay.
-The thing is, none of this
is working.
Yesterday, Trump got yet another
devastating poll result
when Quinnipiac found
that he was behind by Biden
by 15 points, and that a
stunning 60 percent of Americans
disapprove of Trump's
job performance.
I guess my only question about
that is, who are the other 40?
Do they all work
at the Lysol factory?
And yes, I know we've been
here before,
so we absolutely must be
cautious.
It is by no means a given
that Trump will lose.
But as NBC News reported
this week, the Trump campaign
has struggled to land
a punch on Biden.
As NBC reported, the Trump
campaign feels like
none of the president's
attacks have worked.
He has tried tagging Biden as
untrustworthy -- "Corrupt Joe"
and lethargic --
"Sleepy Joe" --
but it hasn't dragged Biden down
with voters as Trump had hoped.
"Sleepy sounds pretty good
when you've had four years
of exhaustion," a White House
official quipped.
And it's hard to tag someone
else as sleepy and corrupt
when you look
like a Mafia don
who falls asleep
in his spaghetti.
But yeah, "Sleepy" sounds
great, and that's Biden.
He's a human Ambien.
He's so boring that even when
he starts telling a story
about some knife fight
between rival gangs
at a public pool, your
first reaction is to say,
"Don't start until
I get my blanket!"
And that's great.
You know what I'd give to go
one day without waking up
and immediately seeing
six different news alerts
on my phone about crazy [bleep]
the president did?
At this point, I'd vote for one
of those drinking birds.
So now Trump is shaking up
his campaign,
demoting his campaign manager,
Brad Parscale,
after the campaign's
embarrassing Tulsa debacle,
in which Trump spoke to
an empty arena that somehow
also managed to seed
a coronavirus outbreak.
And I'm no expert,
but generally speaking,
things are not going great
when you're firing
your campaign manager 100 days
before the election.
That's like a jockey jumping off
his horse in the home stretch
and deciding to run
the rest of the way.
But hey, at least Parscale can
go back to his old job
as the, I don't know,
drummer for a Norwegian
black metal band?
Dude looks like an out-of-shape
Conor McGregor.
Trump's campaign is sputtering
because the coronavirus crisis
isn't a problem Trump can
just B.S. his away out of.
It's a real thing with
real consequences,
and the only way to make those
go away is by governing,
which is just not
in his skill set.
In fact, when it comes to
actually governing,
Trump has had one very
specific obsession
since the start of the this
pandemic, and that's
his obsession with slowing down
testing for coronavirus
so he can hide the numbers and
make himself him look better.
And because Trump isn't just a
criminal, but a dumb criminal,
he has openly confessed
to this many times.
One of the first times
was in back in March
when he said publicly
that he would prefer
not to let American coronavirus
patients off a cruise ship,
because it would make
the numbers worse.
-I mean, frankly,
if it were up to me,
I would be inclined to say,
"Leave everybody on the ship
for a period of time and
use the ship as your base."
But a lot of people would rather
do it a different way.
They would rather quarantine
people when they land.
Now, when they do that, our
numbers are going to go up,
Okay?
Our numbers are going to go up.
They would like to have
the people come off.
I'd like to have the people
stay, but I'd go with them.
I told them to make
the final decision.
I would rather --
because I like the numbers
being where they are.
I don't need to have the numbers
double because of one ship.
I'd rather have them stay on,
personally.
-That's right.
President Jigsaw over here
openly said he wanted to keep
Americans trapped on an infected
cruise ship like some sort of
coronavirus-themed escape room.
Which, even if there was
no coronavirus
would still be a punishment,
because no one ever leaves
an escape room happier
than when they entered.
In my experience, there's always
a fight or whose fault it was
that you couldn't solve
the riddle hidden under
the fortuneteller's
crystal ball or whatever.
"Beth, I told you there was
a clue in the tarot cards,
but you spent all your time
rubbing the magic genie lamp!
Happy birthday, Beth,
and go to hell!"
Trump has repeated this desire
to hide the true extent
of the crisis from Americans
many times.
At a White House event
on Monday, for example,
a reporter asked him about
the lie that more testing
leads to more cases,
and he offered this
truly incoherent response.
-President Trump, you've said
many times that the number
of coronavirus cases is going up
because testing is increasing.
-That's right.
-Do you acknowledge
that it's going up
for other reasons, too?
For example, that it's actually
spreading?
And what are you going to do
to stop the spread?
-Well, you know that we have
one of the lowest
mortality rates anywhere.
If you know, Biden and Obama
stopped their testing.
They just stopped it.
You probably know that.
I'm sure you don't want to
report it.
But they stopped testing.
Right in the middle, they just
went, "No more testing,"
and on a much lesser problem
than the problem that we have,
obviously, with respect to
this is the worst thing that's
happened since probably 1917.
This is a very bad --
all over the world.
It's 188 countries right now.
But, no, we are -- we test more
than anybody, by far.
And when you test,
you create cases.
So we've created cases.
-Okay. There's so much
brain diarrhea
to wade through here,
I might have to borrow
the sea captain's ship.
-Arrgh, she's hearty vessel!
But no match for that
rusty chop!
-Gross, okay.
First of all, you're not
"creating" cases.
The cases are there, whether you
test for them or not.
You don't "create" a fire
by putting a smoke alarm
in your house.
If someone gets sick,
they're sick whether they
get tested or not.
It's not like they're at home
lying in bed with
a 104-degree fever
and no sense of taste or smell
saying, hey, "As long
as I don't get tested,
I don't have
to get treated!
Now to spend the next three days
crawling to my kitchen."
Second, why do you keep saying
the 1918 Spanish flu pandemic
happened in 1917?
Trump has said this more times
than I can count,
and apparently just no one
has corrected him.
-We have a very unusual
situation
where something came
in that nobody has seen
for many, many decades,
probably 1917 would be
the closest analogy,
if you look at it.
The likes of which this world
has not seen since 1917.
Nothing like this since 1917.
Last time was -- of this
magnitude, 1917.
That's a long time ago.
-We haven't seen anything like
this in 100 and some-odd years.
1917.
But 1917, so that's over
100 years ago.
1917, which was the greatest
of them all.
Right? 1917.
In 1917, had they had
the Internet and all the means
of communication, they could
have practiced distancing.
1917, the pandemic.
It was something.
1917.
That's something.
You all know what happened
in 1917.
The big one was 1917.
1917.
Who would have thought?
-It's weird, because it's
arguably the least offensive
thing he's ever done, and yet
it's so infuriating.
Just get it right.
It's like if Genghis Khan kept
saying "supposably."
But of course
he got the year wrong.
He's probably been getting
dates wrong his whole life.
Last year, he sent Don Jr.
a birthday card that said,
"Congrats on turning 8
or whatever."
So Trump has been very clear
about the fact
that he wants to
slow down testing
because it makes him
look bad.
And now, he's getting his wish.
Today, it was reported
that the CDC had removed
some coronavirus
hospital data from its website
after the Trump administration
announced a plan
to send that information to the
administration and not the CDC.
And I'm sorry,
but the last person I'd trust
with any kind of data
is Donald Trump.
The dude brags that he can
drink water with one hand
and identify a camel
on a piece of paper.
You'd think he just got out
of a decade-long coma.
And on top of that, we're
once again we're seeing
nationwide testing problems
and delays,
with cars lined up for hours
in the scorching heat
and a major testing company
announcing that
the turnaround for tests
is now seven days,
with some
waiting even longer.
-I'm Carter Evans in
California,
where lines just to
get a COVID test
stretch for blocks.
In Arizona, one of
the hardest hit states,
the wait is up to 12 hours.
-The turnaround time
for our testing in Arizona
is really bad.
You can get your test
and those results
may not come back
for seven or eight days.
-It took eight days for Atlanta
mayor Keisha Lance Bottoms
to learn she was positive.
-Eight days?
It takes as long
to get your COVID test
as it took Trump to
get down that ramp.
Ramp joke.
If we had two cameras,
that would have been --
we would have
taken a close-up there.
What's the point of even
getting a test
if it takes that long for
the results to come back?
It's like if your car alarm
went off
eight hours after it was stolen.
Trump's getting exactly
what he wanted, slower testing.
Meanwhile, Trump
and the people around him
are tested constantly, and their
results come back right away.
As long as they're safe, Trump
couldn't care less about you.
But voters see through it,
which is why his poll numbers
are bad as they've ever been.
The Biden campaign must turn on
the news every day
and say to themselves...
-Our numbers are
going to go up.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
-So many New Yorkers are
needing to turn to City Harvest
for help feeding their families,
and they need your support
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wear a mask.
We love you.